[Music]
darcy leffler has a question since
moving to austin it appears to me that
you've become more reflective if this is
the case what brought this about what
has been the impact on your life
i think i have been more reflective in
the last few years and
i think that that
can be attributed in part to moving to
austin certainly but more so it's moving
out of san francisco i think that i
would have been more reflective
had i moved to
who knows
montana or pennsylvania
as long as i was outside of a major city
even though austin is a city it is not
one dominated by a
mono culture or a mono conversation in
the same way that san francisco is
dominated by tech it is pervasive it is
soaked drenched in tech tech tech
los angeles in many parts is drenched
and soaked in entertainment
entertainment entertainment and
it's very easy to end up in and not just
an echo chamber
but
in a race where you feel like a
greyhound chasing that rabbit around the
track and you never quite catch it no
one quite catches it everyone has agreed
upon the rules
seems to think it's important and it's
it's a pull to the external in many
senses so by removing myself somewhat
from that environment
even though austin has a million people
or so in the greater austin area
i've been able to kind of recalibrate
and think about which interests of mine
are actually mine or those that i've
absorbed or inherited which
drives of mine
are mine
or simply
absorbed through osmosis in some
conscious or unconscious way
subconscious way if need be and
i think that has caused me particularly
as i contemplate
family fatherhood and so on
it has brought up a lot of the big
questions where do i want to be and why
what do i want to be doing and why what
do i not want to be doing and why who do
i want to spend more time with
as
the sort of horizon at
the the vanishing point at the end of my
life draws closer now that i am at least
based on the
historical ages of death in my family on
both sides for men i'm past the halfway
mark
who do i want to deepen relationships
with do i want to deepen relationships
with people i already know do i want to
develop new friendships
and in either case why with whom
and
these are questions that take time at
least for me to explore properly and to
really think on and to journal on and to
test
also
so i think that it's it's been the
removal from a high density urban
environment with a monoculture or a mono
conversation i should note that even in
a rural place or a smaller city it is
possible to put yourself in
circumstances such that you end up
in echo chambers
so i've also been very deliberate about
trying to avoid that
and i hope that helps to answer the
answer the question i've also had a lot
of death in my family uh
my uncle just in the last few weeks died
of an alcohol induced
heart failure and passed away on the day
literally to the day of richard nixon's
announcement of the drug war 50 years
ago
uh calling
public enemy number one drugs and
uh it just goes to highlight for me at
least that better treatments are part of
the answer not necessarily better
punishments and
these have all caused me to pause these
types of events
periods of mourning and so on
so
whether i like it or not i've been given
opportunities to reflect and i'm
grateful at least for that
you